[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud proud and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] em
[Music]
court
[Music]
thursday
we have a lot of decisions from the
supreme court dropping
including one of the most breaking
decisions that they're gonna give today
apparently today
today on thursday june 23rd
the bought and paid for justices of the
supreme court
are against states rights tomorrow
they're going to be four states rights
you know let's be very clear about this
today
today they're against
states rights
to actually have some sort of regulation
on firearms in particular conceal and
carry firearms
today they're against those states
rights tomorrow
tomorrow we're going to find out that
they're all for states rights to tell
women what they can and can't do with
their bodies
can't tell people what to do with a gun
definitely tell
women what they can do
with their uterus 100 percent
that's how you view states rights in the
constitution
in 2022.
i'm not saddened by this a lot of people
are freaking out this is very dangerous
i will agree and there's going to be
people lose their lives over this
decision
people are going to get killed
because you can now just do whatever the
[ __ ] you want whenever you want
with a weapon
and it's going not just to affect the
state of new york
it's going to affect several other
states
i think it's seven exactly that have
these
type of laws
where you actually have to receive some
sort of permission a regulation you know
like
as if that amendment that they talk
about is has the words well regulated in
it
reading the second amendment might
[ __ ] help
but here we have
the supreme court laying down the
decision and it's
not surprising
but it's six to three
this is why a lot of people are arguing
to have a supreme court justice for each
district
and expand the court which is what they
have always done when they expand
districts besides now
because they want to push their ideology
on us
through the court
even even
thomas saying
look at this language of the look at the
language yeah look at it
it says militia number one
you there's definitions to that [ __ ]
word
and then it says well regulated number
two
yeah look at the language it's clear in
text black and white
it really is not that complicated
this [ __ ] bastardization
of the individual right for someone to
carry any weapon anywhere anytime
anywhere they want for whatever [ __ ]
reason
is really boneheaded it's really stupid
it doesn't even say that it's not what
it says
at all
i mean they bought and paid for this
decision
so
now it does say that because it's an
official decision from the supreme court
but if this doesn't get in your crawl
and make you resolve even more for our
democracy i don't i don't i i can't tell
you
what is going to happen tomorrow then
because tomorrow's really gonna [ __ ]
piss you off
it's really gonna piss you off
because they're gonna do the opposite
that they're doing today that the state
does not have the right to tell someone
it is against your
liberty to regulate
as it says in the text
firearms
it says it right there it it's clear as
day it's not
it's not hard to understand
it says
well
regulated militia number one
your cousin earl
who is terrified of going into a subway
to order a an italian bmt without an
assault rifle or a handgun
that's not a militia that fat [ __ ] your
cousin earl
who dresses up in in in
[ __ ]
gravy seals cosplay
that's not a well-regulated militia
he's just a dumb [ __ ]
everyone's got their cousin earl
somewhere
i mean rather they're your cousin or you
just know of this dumb [ __ ] that lives
down the street
that's not a militia
that's not even close to the definition
of militia
and these these
these [ __ ] originalists they claim
they're originalist
they're original on everything but the
second amendment
like they're unwilling to go back i mean
they'll go back to take away women's
liberty they'll go back 400 years to
text a thousand years hell let's go back
5 thousand years when they were
scratching on cave walls let's do that
to justify taking away women's liberty
but when you're talking about the second
amendment
and really trying to make sure that you
get your way
going back and looking at the context of
the time well that would just be stupid
because what would happen
is
the exact opposite of the desired result
here
so they're not going to go back and
contextually look at the [ __ ] second
amendment and the definitions of the
word in the son of a [ __ ] especially
with the time that they were writing
them down on the [ __ ] piece of paper
wouldn't do that it would have the
opposite of the desired result
which is the desired result is for them
to carry weapons and to have people in
fear
that's their desire here
who in the actual [ __ ] needs to protect
themselves from anybody but these
[ __ ] gun nuts when you're ordering a
sandwich at subway
who are you protecting besides each
other you're protecting against the
people like eric greitens
that's why we want red flag laws
someone like him who's accused
of crimes who's accused of abusing
his wife and his child and then he puts
out a political ad saying we're gonna
kick in your door and we're gonna come
kill you with our guns
and even even when i get in the
government we're gonna have the army
and the military with us to come kick in
the door and kill you with our guns if
you disagree with us inside our own
party that's what we're gonna do
it's fear
it's fear that's all this is it's the
same thing as marjorie taylor green
shooting a [ __ ] toyota prius with a
gun
now inside this decision
apparently
there's sensitive areas
you can't i mean
we cannot infringe on someone's right to
carry a gun unless unless it's you know
close to a supreme court justice's house
or maybe maybe one of these gq peers who
by the way
has to be
on board with the entire manga ideology
because if you're not they'll come kick
in your door and kill you so guns it's
no longer a sensitive area sensitive
area
because they're marking out sensitive
areas because they know
they have to keep certain places safe
and the only way to keep certain places
safe from guns is to not have guns in
those places
so we will i don't know do the whole
regulating thing
this is really [ __ ] boneheaded folks
this is really [ __ ] stupid
the american people
are are not gonna buy into this nonsense
they don't they don't we've seen 14
senators muster up enough courage to do
the bare minimum the absolute bare
minimum
of what the majority of americans want
only 14 of them can muster enough
courage to advance the debate of the
bill
not vote for it
not say yeah i'm for that just say well
maybe we should talk about this in the
senate maybe we should debate this
language
the bare minimum
this isn't some kind of [ __ ] radical
gun reform this is [ __ ] that americans
want
time after time after time every time we
have children slaughtered innocent
people in a grocery store slaughtered
parishioners in a church slaughtered
every single [ __ ] time we do poll
after poll after poll and it shows that
the american people want to make sure
that guns are not getting into the wrong
hands and we're doing something about it
we're doing something about that that's
the bare minimum
we're not talking about an assault
weapons ban we're not talking about this
concealed carry handguns and banning
handguns and assault rifle we're not
talking about that
bare minimum [ __ ]
waiting period back on track check if
you've had violence in your past yeah
maybe you should be questioned whether
you should have a [ __ ] gun
it's not complicated
it's what american wants but damn what
america wants
[ __ ] that [ __ ] the hell with that
that's not good enough because we can't
strike how is eric greitens and the rest
of the gqp the trump these trumped-up
[ __ ] candidates gonna strike fear in
the hearts of other republicans if
they're if they're dissidents
oh they're killing liberals folks that
they're they're not going to stop
at the dissonance of their own party
i mean they're first
that's that's how they that's how they
do it that's how fascist that's how
authoritarians do it is they kill the
dissidents first
that's who goes first
tony such harsh language
i don't know what to tell you i i can't
i can't give you anything but what the
[ __ ] in history tells us about
authoritarians and dictators and
fascists
i don't know what else to [ __ ] tell
you
and what they're gonna say is oh but but
fascists take the guns
they take them they don't give the guns
if you really see this as a
as the
as the liberty
that you can just carry around a weapon
as opposed to the liberty
of being safe in a public space
and being able to i don't know well
regulate the militia
and the right to bear arms this is
really [ __ ] boneheaded type [ __ ]
i'm struck
by the fascist party in our country
struck by it i mean it
and we shouldn't be surprised i guess
it's this notion
that
for instance just this week we
we watched
as rusty bowers the arizona house
speaker
testified
that donald trump and his allies tried
to get him to illegally break his oath
of office
and the reason why rusty bowers was
unwilling to do that's because it was a
crime and it was his sacred oath and god
and the bible and whatever the [ __ ] he
said
and as soon as he was not under oath
meaning he didn't have the
the liability of perjuring himself he
stood in front of an ap reporter and
said of course i would vote for donald
trump why the hell wouldn't you i mean
jesus christ they're gonna come kicking
your door and kill you if you don't
that's what this is about
that's what this second amendment bros
shit's about
it's about fear striking fear
in the hearts of americans
pushing them
inch by inch millimeter by millimeter
to accept fascism just accept it just
accept that's what you're going to do
you can do nothing about it
nothing we bought and paid for the
supreme court and now they will rain
down on you
our ideology and you will have to bend
to their will
that is not true
[ __ ] that [ __ ] you do not have to do
that
you don't they're not forcing you to
carry they can't force you to carry
that's the whole point of the second
amendment that's why these [ __ ]
boneheads don't get it they can't force
you to carry a gun
on every side of the right
you have the right not
again
freedom of speech
what do they read you in miranda because
that was another decision today you have
the right to remain silent
your freedom of speech isn't just the
freedom to speak
you have the freedom to be silent to not
self-incriminate yourself or to
capitulate to towards the fascist
as we're seeing
all over this country in the republican
party
who is now the fascist party
you had the right you had the right to
freedom of speech but you also have the
right to remain silent
you have the right to own a gun in this
country that is what the second
amendment says you have the right to own
a gun
you also have the right not to own one
you don't have to own one
it's not a thing that you have to do
you're not forced to do that
your freedom of religion you you have
the freedom to have religion
you have the freedom to have it
without being punished by the government
of what religion that you hold
but you also have the right not to have
it you see you see how it works
you [ __ ] dummies do you see how it
works
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating morons
it's in the [ __ ] the intro
every single show
i'll say it again the freedom to oppress
the rights of other people
is not liberty
we strive for liberty in this country
liberty is what we are trying to achieve
yes it's difficult
democracy is one of the most difficult
forms of government
but it also
delivers
as close as you can get to equity and
equality over time it's difficult to get
there we know that from our country's
history
and we shouldn't back away from that
history
jesus christ this law that they
overturned in new york city or new york
state of new york
it's a hundred year old law
it's a hundred years old this law that
they overturned
talk about
history but we strive for liberty in
this country
that's that's what we're going for
that's what we're supposed to achieve
and the way that we do that is our
freedoms and our rights
but people get these things so [ __ ]
confused
it's so
clear that we as pro-democracy people if
you're listening to me right now and you
believe in democracy
it is so clear
now
that we hold tight
to not just our ideas of democracy but
our institutions of democracy that this
morning i think keith olbermann is is
trending because he's saying to you know
cast out the supreme court
we have to tear the entire supreme court
down
well that's not liberty
that's not liberty
that doesn't liberate
the the democracy
that undermines the democracy that
undermines the institution
of checks and balances as much as we
have steered away from it it's because
we've kept our eye off the ball folks
we the people are the [ __ ] government
we are the democracy it is us
and as long as the majority of we the
people
still believe in those democratic
institutions still believe in those
democratic ideas
that yes it is us who gets to decide
it's difficult because we disagree on a
lot of different [ __ ]
especially details of a lot of different
[ __ ]
but if we can all agree
that yes
liberty is the thing that we strive for
and the rights and the freedoms that are
granted to us by our constitution that
we keep in place because it's important
to us to have that constitution and the
foundation of our democracy
then those freedoms and rights will
deliver us
to liberty
we have to believe that
regardless regardless of decisions like
today and more
like decisions like tomorrow that
tomorrow
is going to be
a groundbreaking moment in this country
when the supreme court
rips away a right that is granted by the
constitution
to someone who is pregnant
rip it away from them
rip it away from him a real right to
your bodily autonomy
the actual freedom to choose what you do
with your body
and that's what delivers your liberty
so many of these mogalodites these
trumped-up white people
think that freedom is your it's it's
your right to walk in a grocery store
and have at least 30 different brands of
pizza to choose from to put in the oven
because we want frozen pizza and it's
also our freedom and our right
to have dozens of choices of hot dogs
that we can cook
this is really [ __ ] boneheaded
they've lost their way folks they're
deluded they're delusional
and yes it's the fascists that are
drawing them down this road i mean
really unfortunately it's a small
percentage in this country but it's a
large number of people who actually
believe that we're not even a democracy
they're like ah constitutional republic
well that's not a democracy i mean it it
did the definition
i mean words have definitions and they
[ __ ] mean things but they don't to
these people they don't
they're scared
terrified of democracy because democracy
delivers those rights and freedoms and
that liberty
eventually to all people
and that's what they [ __ ] hate
that's what they [ __ ] hate because
equality and
equity to the privileged oh boy does it
feel like oppression
wow if they're getting something i must
have something taken away from me
it's the same [ __ ] they've been selling
these [ __ ] for decades about
taxes well if we tax the rich then
they're gonna tax me
it affects me
you're really [ __ ] dumb
but here we are and what do we do i mean
that's gonna be the question especially
after tomorrow
after tomorrow when the when the
decision comes down to strike down roe v
wade
and state after state after state
starts to
undo rights
that women have to their bodily autonomy
we're going to start to see that women
in some states
are second-class citizens
because they do not have the full
liberty
that other people in other states
have just like we've seen in our history
before
with blacks
with women and voting
we've seen this before it's part of our
history we shouldn't steer away from it
matter of fact
we should embrace it and tell the story
because that story
will deliver us
closer to the equity and equality that
we desire
through our democracy and those rights
and that freedom
to get to that liberty
but tomorrow they're going to strip it
away
tomorrow
and it won't stop there they're not
going to they're not going to just stop
tomorrow like oh roe v wade's overturned
well we did that so we'll we'll move on
we'll move on to something different
they're not
they're gonna do exactly with roe v wade
what they did today
with making sure that people in the
state of new york are unsafe because
anyone and everyone can just carry
around a gun
for no on whatever reason they want
because you know it's the wild west pew
pew pew pew pew
wild [ __ ] west which what's funny
about that is in the wild west they
didn't actually let you carry your
[ __ ] guns around
just saying
like that's what the whole okay corral
thing was over you know wyatt earp that
[ __ ] movie it was because people were
trying to carry [ __ ] guns where they
weren't allowed to carry [ __ ] guns so
they end up killing each other
it's not it's it's not complicated it's
it's easy to go back and look at what
happened
but they're not going to stop at roe v
wade tomorrow they're going to do the
same thing they're doing today with this
law in the state i mean today they hate
states rights tomorrow they'll love
states rights in the states that want to
take away your liberty
and then watch them turn very quickly as
soon as that decision is made as soon as
the decision is made to strike down roe
v wade in the in the in the guise of
states rights
they'll have the narrative that it's not
the state's rights
to allow abortion
that's what they'll say
nope
absolutely not
we want states rights when it suits us
but we don't want them when it doesn't
suit us
because they're fascists they they have
no
no qualms
with building a narrative
around the complete utter falsehood
we've seen this with this second
amendment for decades and decades and
decades that they built this false
narrative around a well-regulated
militia that's the [ __ ] words read
the goddamn amendment read that
[ __ ]
read it
just read the son of a [ __ ] and if you
have to go look up each one of those
[ __ ] words go look them up see what
the definition is decipher it for
yourself
yeah i'm not going to do that here on
the air
if you're not [ __ ] if you're not
smart enough to go look at the words and
read the goddamn text and then look up
the goddamn definitions and make a real
logical [ __ ]
choice about what those words mean
then yeah i i'm not going to be able to
convince you and we're not we're not
going to be able to convince a lot of
these people
that's not a thing that's going to
happen folks jesus christ they're out
from underneath their rocks donald trump
has given them permission time and time
and time again
to be out underneath these rocks
so one of the problems that we got
for a long time
this fascist ideology has lived in the
shadows
you know under the thin veiled
thin veiled guise of conservatism
he's done it for
for a long time
knife spoke about it with liz cheney and
adam kinzinger
that yes are they doing the right thing
sure absolutely they're doing the right
thing by being on the january 6 select
committee
which we're going to hear from more
today
this afternoon
but are they part of the coming out from
underneath the rock you goddamn right it
took liz cheney 190 days folks 100
remember this
she is on the side of truth now but it
took her 190 days to get to the house
floor to tell the truth
190 days from after the election it took
liz cheney to get to the floor of the
house to declare that yes yes it is a
fact that joe biden won and trump lost
it's not complicated
it is a fact
and from that moment on she was on the
side of truth which
is fine
i mean she's not she's she's not our
ally
other than she
adheres to this truth
this known truth
but we can't forget who these
[ __ ] are
liz cheney the adam kinzingers the kevin
mccarthy's and the mitch mcconnells
liberals were excited that 14 that 14
republican senators did the bare minimum
to make sure that the filibuster didn't
stop the debate
for the bare minimum of gun reform
and gun safety that
that americans want
that's that's that was everyone cheering
democrats are really [ __ ] dumb they
should have been out pounding these son
of a [ __ ] it well it's about goddamn
time you pieces of [ __ ] [ __ ]
you're doing the bare minimum you don't
get a reward for doing the bare minimum
they didn't even vote for it they just
voted to debate the son of a [ __ ]
everyone thinks it's past and it's law
no it's not that ain't how it works
they just made sure that the american
people knew that they weren't against
the senate debating rather we should
have these
common sense gun safety things because
they seen the number they seen the c
wave against them
but today the supreme court has very
many decisions but the one that stands
out obviously at this point with the
breaking news is the second amendment
and the reason why it's going to be
stand out is because they're going to be
out pounding their chest they're going
to be out and show they're going to be
out in force they're going to want to
they're going to want to exercise this
new rat that they have
which is kind of funny that it's a new
right if it's a new right if it was
always right why is it new now
now that they've overturned this
hundred-year law in the state of new
york which it looks like that seven
other states will have to follow to take
these laws off the books
now they're a little different from
state to state
but there's several states that have
similar laws connecticut california and
a few others
but the thing that gets me the most in
this decision is they could talk about
they talk about sensitive areas
sensitive oh it's real sensitive you
talk about [ __ ] sensitive
[ __ ] what do you mean sensitive
you mean like like anywhere near brett
kavanaugh's home
no one can carry even a right winger
what about what about someone in a manga
hat
you can't carry a handgun if you're in a
maga hat i mean i don't know it seems
like you know you would not be a rhino
if you were wearing a maga hat maybe
maybe non-rhinos could carry anywhere
they want even in the sensitive areas
maybe that's where they're going next
who knows
who knows because the only good guy with
the gun is the guy who breaks down the
door to kill rhinos with a gun right
isn't that a good guy with a gun
clearly
we have a disease in our country clearly
and it's metastasizing
and hopefully
that the country will pluck its head out
of its ass
and cut off this cancer
before it kills us
today is the day that we are going to
start that process again with day 5 of
the january 6th select hearings
where we start to pull back the curtain
on trumpism and the crimes
that trump and his allies committed on
our democracy
we're going to hear from the doj
officials
jeffrey rosen
richard donahue and stephen engel
and these are the guys when bill barr
quit just to give you a quick synopsis
here these are the guys when bill barr
quit because he's like nope i'm not
going to federal prison for you dumb
buck just like rusty bauer said on
tuesday nope i'm not going to prison for
you rudy giuliani for you jen ellis for
you donald trump bill barr's like i'm
not going to go i'm not going to do
prison time for you you dumbass so he
quit
these are the three guys that were in
line and trump said oh you won't do my
bidding well i'll appoint jeffrey clark
who will do my bidding
he'll do my bidding he'll commit crimes
for me
and these three guys are like okay well
if you do that we'll resign
we're not going to do the criming thing
that's yeah i think that's probably a
scenario i mean we're going to have
better commentary
and more extensive commentary than that
and i know we'll hear from this
testimony of jeffrey rosen richard
donahue and stephen engel today now the
former acting attorney general the
former acting deputy attorney general
and the former assistant attorney
general um for the office of legal
counsel
so we're going to see those parts in the
testimony today now i want to give you
news because you know we're live right
now i'm going to be live like almost all
day because we're here live right now
with the tony michaels pad podcast as we
are every single weekday
every single weekday
we are live
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific
on youtube twitter twitch and
simulcasting from the midas touch
facebook page
and here's the thing
today
at two o'clock eastern is normally when
we exactly end this show
we will be broadcasting
the
january 6th select hearing day five
hearings with commentary we do an hour
before because the gavel will go down at
three o'clock
eastern in the afternoon but we will do
an hour of commentary before
i want to give a great announcement here
today we will hear from the mizellas
brothers i believe ben's going to give
us a good rundown of these witnesses
that are going to appear today
uh from the perspective of the witnesses
who they are but also the legal aspect
of who they are and what their jobs were
and what we know about
the public
evidence so far and maybe surmise what
they're going to testify to we're also
we're also going to hear from texas paul
the mind as mighty out there knows texas
paul is a favorite and i have a special
special special guest
today on the first hour
of commentary before the hearing we are
going to hear from president ronald
reagan's son ron reagan he did a video
for midas touch a couple weeks ago
i believe or last week it's hard to pick
this stuff is running together for me
but ron reagan is going to join us in
the very first hour to talk about the
january 6 select hearings and our
democracy and what this all means for
our democracy
so ron reagan will join us so be sure be
sure because here's what we're going to
do i'm going to end this broadcast about
15 15-20 minutes early than i normally
do to give myself time to prepare
to start the broadcast over on midas
touch channel their youtube channel
at two o'clock p.m eastern
again we're gonna do an hour before the
hearing starts of commentary so you guys
get a good idea what's gonna happen
at that hearing
so come join us on the midas touch
youtube channel go over there i'll post
that link here
um i'm the only one running the show
today too um gabe sanchez is on an
airplane i believe or in an airport
right now um but he's gonna be on an
airplane so he's not gonna be able to
help me uh run run all the run all the
the doodads and the widgets and the
go-getters and all that
so i'm by myself today so stay with me
here
today we are going to do about an hour
and 40 hour and 45 minutes of our two
hours regular and then what we're going
to do is take a little break and then
we're going to jump over to the midas
touch youtube channel
to talk
commentary for an hour before the gavel
falls
for day five of the january 6 select
hearings the public hearings were
jeffrey rosen the former acting attorney
general richard donahue the former
acting deputy attorney general and
stephen engel the former assistant
attorney general for the office of legal
counsel will testify in front of the
january 6th select hearing today in
public
i'm not sure exactly i don't i don't
know if it's raskin
or if it's shift going to be running
this uh hearing today on some of the
questions so that should be interesting
to see as well so again
we will broadcast here live until we
take that break
and then we will go over to the midas
touch youtube page so don't forget to
find that link i will put that link in
the chat here so stay with us
i'll put that link in the chat
so you guys have it when this broadcast
is over
um and i'm gonna take a quick break here
don't go anywhere and if you do go
somewhere go set a reminder for that
link over on minus youtube channel and
then come back here because we will be
back
right after this break we'll be right
back
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capitol have you been left out in
the cold after stealing nancy pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi i'm paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket i've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on january 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of congress who also helped with the
attempted coup pardon blanket will
protect you too pardon blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the usa
don't delay and get your part in blanket
today for just
99.99 actual parting's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the tony
michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking around to the break
i'm gonna get this link for you here in
the
[Music]
to
chat
youtube page
there you go there's that there's that
uh
oh man i need
it's not having gabe sanchez my
executive producer and co-host running
the widgets and the doodads over here
i'm trying i'm trying to do several
different things i'm trying to run the
show here and i'm also trying to get
everything set up over there
over there's
so there's the link in the chat so if
you want the link in the chat there's
the link in the chat go right now and
set your reminder now and come right
back here so go set your reminder and
then push the back button so you can
come back here
now because we still have another hour
another hour
of the tony michaels podcast
here on youtube twitter twitch also
subscribe to our channel
while you're here on youtube you do not
want to miss a single episode we
broadcast every single weekday monday
through friday noon eastern 11 central
nine pacific for two full hours of
course today it's a little longer
because we have the special select
hearing
but we broadcast two full hours monday
through friday
and today's thursday so all the uh
all the listeners out there
who have been with us but for the new
listeners that don't know today on
thursday we always put out the bonehead
of the week poll
where you choose the bone hen of the
week
and on fridays in the second hour
me and gabe sanchez break down the
bonehead of the week so don't forget to
go follow us on twitter at tonymichael's
pod that's where you will find the poll
you can also find the poll here on
youtube so don't forget to subscribe
here on youtube we do a poll on each
place youtube and twitter
the nice part about this podcast is it's
also
able to be downloaded on apple spotify
google or your favorite directory don't
forget to download every single episode
if you don't want to look at my pretty
face well then maybe you'll go listen to
my pretty voice
over on the directories and make sure to
you know leave us
leave us a
review and give us a good review and
five stars all that kind of good stuff
over there
also if you want to join the super chat
and youtube if you're not aware what the
super chat is don't worry come on over
here talk to the people in the super
chat on youtube
and you will
be able to
find out exactly what the super chat is
speaking of chat boy the the porn bots
are out today holy [ __ ]
i'm trying to man
i'm trying to i need we we i'm trying to
manage the porn bots here i don't know
if you guys see this but holy [ __ ]
they're just everywhere
they're everywhere they're everywhere so
i'm trying i'm trying here i'm trying to
run the show and do this
but for all the new listeners out there
we got a lot of new listeners here on
the broadcast today
we we
go through the tweety tweets and the
trendy trends every single weekday
monday through friday we trying to go
through the tweety tweets and training
trends what's happening out there on the
[ __ ] list roundup
so let's start the countdown and let's
get to the [ __ ] list
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking with us
here on the tony michael's podcast
we're going to go through the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends there's a
lot of [ __ ] to get to today a lot of
stuff is trending because of the supreme
court mainly but it looks like we have
some breaking news
um
looks like 16 michigan republicans who
signed a certificate falsely claiming to
cast the state's electoral votes to
donald trump in december 2020 are
receiving grand jury
uh subpoenas from federal officials
today um so this is uh this is news here
let me see if i can pull that up on the
screen now so you guys can see that
there
there we go
um this is from spiro agnew's ghost
um again it says breaking some of the 16
michigan republicans who signed a
certificate falsely claiming to cast
their state's electoral votes to donald
trump in december 2020
are receiving grand jury subpoenas
from federal officials today
that seems significant and what do you
think
see i i i'm really tired of people oh
the there's g.o.j is doing nothing well
here's doj doing something
here it is folks you're seeing it
uh yesterday we talked about andrew
gillum and you remember this guy i guess
he ran for governor against ron desantis
he's a democrat
in 2018 he apparently committed uh
campaign finance uh law he broke fan
federal campaign finance laws now
everyone in this country is entitled to
uh innocence until guilt is proven but
here's the thing is that uh
if you look go back and look 2018 is
when that race was run we're four years
in and this guy is just now thinking
he's going to get indicted this [ __ ]
takes time now to be fair and with the
january 6
and the the stole the steel of our
democracy which we're seeing more and
more layout in these january 6
hearings
uh it's going to take a little bit of
time but they've hired so many people
and there's so much focus but there's so
many people involved in this thing it's
not just like a three people involved in
this thing this thing had
many different tiers it had many
different levels there were many
different schemes
for trump to take over the government be
the dictator i mean when you're a
buffoon when you're a stupid [ __ ] when
you're a stupid [ __ ] your best bet is to
have as many
as many cards to play as you possibly
can
when you're gonna try to take over
democracy and [ __ ] on it
like that's
you know
you want to have as many cards to play
so you know he had the doj which we're
going to hear about today in the
hearings over on the midas touch youtube
channel when we broadcast the hearing
live
we're going to hear the doj part of the
plan we've we heard this part of the
state electors and this
and the pressure that the giuliani and
jenna ellis and donald trump were
putting on state officials on tuesday
when they were trying to pressure not
just not just the elected officials but
even
election workers and the volunteers they
were putting on miss moss and her mother
and even their grandmother
they were trying to put pressure on them
now we
we
we saw the one leg of of the coup
attempt where they were trying to
pressure mike pence to declare donald
trump king
well that was that was another thing
well there you go
oh man there's another leg there's
another card that they were trying to
play
and now we see this breaking news of
these 16 michigan republicans uh who
were part of this uh fraudulent state
electors
scheme there's another leg of it there's
another leg where they were trying to
trying to subvert our democracy and
steal it away
um i have some
video i want to play here
um
if i can find
exactly what i want here
[Music]
bear with me
i'm not finding it let's just go to the
tweety tweets and trendy trends here
let's go to the
trends um
we have it at the very top second
amendment of course
and of course it's it's full up it's
full up with right wingers yay
we can now carry to scare anyone we want
in this great
we get to carry our weapons to scare
anyone on the streets that we want
and really use and really use the little
dick energy
of a handgun
to terrify people
because yeah you know that's what it is
it's little dick energy now the new york
daily news has the top headline here
breaking supreme court rules new york
century old concealed carry handgun law
violated the second amendment
and a 6-3 decision which is the court's
most significant gun rights ruling in
more than a decade
voided the state's sullivan act which
again it's a 100-year-old law
kyle uh reports here and put to give him
thanks for that
tweet there kyle reports here uh new
york state governor kathy hogel
responds to the supreme court ruling she
says shocking absolutely shocking
that they have taken away our right to
to reasonable restrictions again she's
talking about the state's rights today
they're against states rights tomorrow
when they overturn the right for women
to have bodily autonomy they'll be four
states rights so today they're against
state rights tomorrow they will be for
them
be assured of that um kyle goes on to
say
quote the governor we can have
restrictions on speech
but somehow there's no restrictions
allowed on the second amendment which is
kind of what this decision is saying
um i'll
tweet the
retweet the quote from the governor of
new york there that kyle has
um
of course again we've got a lot of right
wingers in here just pounding their
chest
you know saying oh yeah
yeah we get to we get to use our fascism
and our handguns to scare anyone we want
wherever we want it's gonna be great
it's gonna be fantastic
now that the american taliban gets to
open carry in any state that they want
i mean that's kind of the hey there we
are let's see
there is a
there's a couple well i thought there
was a couple reports here here here's
msnbc's
uh
uh
report on the breaking news let's watch
this real quick and see what they had to
say there well it was 14 years ago that
the supreme court said that the second
amendment does provide an individual
right to have a gun but they said it was
at home for self-defense and ever since
then the court has declined to answer
the question well what about the part of
the second amendment that says keep and
bear arms what about guns in public and
today the supreme court has answered
that question by a vote of six to three
in an opinion written by justice
clarence thomas saying that the second
amendment does provide a right to have a
gun outside the home now the law in
question in new york said there's no
there's no right to carry a gun openly
in new york but to get a concealed carry
permit a person had to go to the county
sheriff and show some special need
something beyond just a general desire
for self-defense so did you catch that
that's the law in new york that they
were trying to overturn so a century ago
and literally a hundred years ago now
you gotta remember the context here you
gotta remember what guns were like a
hundred years ago verse now right i mean
there's there's a big difference
in the in the
the actual efficiency
of guns then and guns now and by
efficiency i mean you know to protect
yourself or to go into a school and
murder 19 children and two two teachers
you know that kind of efficiency
but there's a difference in efficiency
than a hundred years ago but the what
he is describing here on msnbc
the law
is saying that yeah it's reasonable that
you have to have a reasonable
um a reason to carry a weapon
in public
a hundred years ago
100 years ago they understood this let's
continue
and today the supreme court said that's
unconstitutional
that puts a limit on the right to have a
gun so the supreme court and this is
really [ __ ] stupid this does not put
a limit on having a gun
that's the dumbest [ __ ] thing i've
ever heard in my life it's like saying
well
you know we need to get rid of these
speed limit signs because the speed
limit signs really restrict my right to
have a car like if my car can go 100
miles an hour shouldn't i be able to
drive 100 miles an hour for [ __ ] sake
the idea the idea that that any
regulation placed on something is the
is in any way infringes on your right to
actually possess that thing is [ __ ]
stupid it really is [ __ ] dumb we do
this all day every day with everything
else in this country
everything else point to anything
point me out to anything that isn't as
unregulated as firearms
give it to me show it to me give me the
proof of something that is less
regulated
than firearms
jesus christ they're they're recalling
and the fda the government is telling
jewel
that you can't [ __ ] have cigarettes
e-cigarettes and that's not coming from
some kind of shit-lib democrats that was
started under the trump administration
when they were like oh my god they're
selling strawberry e-cigarette flavoring
which i'm not saying that we should or
shouldn't look at that
but what i am saying is the federal
government has the power
to ban strawberry flavored e-cigarettes
because it's a consumer problem it's a
consumer protection problem and people
may be getting sick and dying from it
yet yet guns go unregulated in the
consumer protection market get the [ __ ]
out of here with this [ __ ] you people
have lost your goddamn minds your
[ __ ] lunatics
you've lost the meaning of words you
don't give a [ __ ] up you don't give a
[ __ ] about what reality is anymore don't
give two shits
if you win just read the [ __ ] second
amendment that you claim the love you
know what the [ __ ] it says and you know
that new york and any other state has
the right to regulate their militia
well-regulated militia
but again today today they're against
states rights tomorrow they'll be for
them
when they have to take women's liberty
away because we have to have this slow
burn fascism let's listen in and with
the for the remainder here it says
number one states cannot put these
special restrictions on getting a gun
for a concealed carry permit now this
decision obviously will have an
immediate effect in new york and it'll
also affect the seven other states that
have similar laws california connecticut
delaware hawaii maryland massachusetts
and new jersey but the opinion also says
that states can restrict areas sensitive
places is what the opinion says there
you go there's the sensitive places and
the sensitive places are the places that
they don't want people like eric
greitens to kick down the door and come
kill them with guns those sensitive
places you know they're going to make
sure to restrict those sins i mean until
until their dissidents and then they're
not sensitive anymore as long as you're
not as long as you're not a dissident it
won't you know
you'll have a sensitive safe space to
live in
they want protections
for themselves
they don't want it for average americans
it's going to continue like this
it will continue to go like this let's
finish up where guns can be off limits
but this is a very important ruling for
second amendment rights the second big
second amendment ruling in our history
it's not an important ruling for second
amendment rights this is a
bastardization of second
amendment that's nonsense too and this
is not some big [ __ ] groundbreaking
thing for the second amendment
you're doing the opposite of what it
[ __ ] says
words mean [ __ ]
just because you have
people like that [ __ ] treacherous son
of a [ __ ] like clarence thomas whose
wife was trying to overthrow the
government
with donald trump and then he he
tries with his vote to block the
evidence to go to january 6 select
committee i wonder why
just because those [ __ ] morons
interpret the language however they want
definitions and reality be damned get
the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
and again it's our democracy it's up to
us we are the ones who let this happen
folks
we are the one who let this happen
we we took our eye off the ball and i
don't just mean like people pro
democracy
people in general
the other day kyrie irving which team he
was going to go on was more important to
americans than our democracy it was
trending they were like oh kyrie irving
where is he going to go he going to go
this team he going to go to that team
well goddamn that's important [ __ ] it
might be important but it's not as
important as the democracy that provides
the ability for kyrie irving or for you
to discuss what [ __ ] team kyrie
irving is gonna be on do you not
understand this do you not get this if
our [ __ ] democracy fails if we just
let it if we just throw it away throw it
in the trash and let authoritarian
the authoritarians take over you don't
get to have the [ __ ] nba the way it
is
you are are you [ __ ] kidding me you
don't you're not gonna have the churches
that you think
you're not
you're not going to have these things
these aren't things that you're going to
you're your community is going to be
different your church is going to be
different your schools you you think
these fascists who are abandoned math
books so people don't know how to
[ __ ] do math so they can't count on
their fingers how many supreme court
justices they're supposed to be
to have a decent [ __ ] fair ruling in
this country
you think those people are gonna keep
public education get the [ __ ] out of
here with that [ __ ]
not gonna happen
not gonna happen they're gonna try to
tear it down
the whole way
and we see it inch by inch here as they
bought and paid for each supreme court
justice that's there
making these [ __ ] decisions
here you go here's an example
training number one is second amendment
where now all people
are in danger of trumped-up people
walking around with handguns
playing [ __ ] cowboy which they don't
know that in the wild west
guns were even more regulated than they
are today no clue no clue same
[ __ ] who are like oh my
grandpappy was a farmer your grandpappy
voted for fdr
your grandpappy was the first socialist
in this country you stupid bastard
here you go number two arch manning
goddamn breaking news class of 2023.
well let's let's go to the presses for a
year from now five star quarterback arch
manning has announced he's gonna play
for the two gives a rat's ass
there won't be texas longhorns i mean
there might be but if there's dissidents
there won't be
eric greitens will go [ __ ] murder him
here's another decision and get coming
in at number three
under under the breaking story that some
some guy with the last name manny's
gonna play at a college somewhere he's
gonna throw a football important [ __ ]
number three politics miranda rights
this is another decision
the supreme court on thursday shielded
police from being sued by suspects for
failing to provide well-known miranda
rights so in other words if they don't
read you your miranda rights you can't
sue them
and more more [ __ ] and here's the jewel
story
here's here's here's the story where the
government can actually regulate things
there you go the fda orders jewel labs
to remove all of its vaping devices and
pods from the u.s market now again if
you remember this was pushed by the
trump administration rightly wrongly
whatever whatever stance you have on
e-cigarettes
i actually believe that we can regulate
the e-cigarettes to where they're not
marketed to children just like we do
cigarettes in this country and you know
there's a motto for this with cigarettes
and alcohol already
we can regulate these things and yeah
you know again we're not going to agree
on everything democracy is difficult but
we can do that
but here you are here you see this story
number five
that the fda is going to remove remove
all vaping devices and pods from the us
market
here they are
here they are admitting that
e-cigarettes are so much more dangerous
than weapons
i mean you know what if that guy down in
umaldi had a jewel what if he [ __ ]
went into that school with a jewel
what would he have done
blew vapor into the into the faces of 19
children and two teachers holy [ __ ] well
god damn we just can't have that
we can't have that we have to regulate
these jewels we have to regulate these
e-cigarettes it's important to our
country the [ __ ] out of here if you can
do that you can regulate guns you sons
of [ __ ]
that's how it works it's how it's worked
for
centuries here [ __ ] out of here with
this [ __ ]
we can't regulate products in this
country just because a handful of people
a handful of families profit from the
manufacture of firearms we can't [ __ ]
regulate them [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you
and again this does not get me
discouraged folks this only pumps me up
it pumps me up for this midterm giving
more [ __ ] reason to vote for
pro-democracy
and anti-fascist
candidates
in the midterm
this doesn't [ __ ] pump you up i don't
know what will because tomorrow is
really going to get your heart going
and i would imagine that these hearings
today are really going to piss you off
as well and get you fired up again we're
going to broadcast from the midas touch
youtube channel as soon as this
broadcast we're going to take a q we're
going to take a break
here in about 35 minutes we'll take a
quick break from the show here
and we'll move to the midas touch
youtube channel for day five
of the january 6th select hearings that
is the news here on the tony michaels
podcast
day five
where we will see the witnesses jeffrey
rosen the former acting attorney general
richard donahue the former acting deputy
attorney general and stephen engel the
former assistant attorney general for
the office of legal counsel
testify to the fact that donald trump
and his allies were trying to pressure
again another pressure campaign to
overturn the election
we're gonna see that today uh here's
number seven the justices
are are trending and then in number
eight keith olbermann is trending uh it
says political commentator keith oberman
appears to promote the legal theory of
nullification
tweeting on thursday that is necessary
to dissolve the supreme court and that
ruling should be ignored by states this
is really [ __ ] dumb by the way that's
right i'm going to call out keith
oberman here this is really [ __ ] dumb
this is not this is not pro-democracy
here
keith olbermann is not being
pro-democracy we have to stop spilling
ourselves
into into this trap of authoritarianism
because
we want something that we can't have in
the moment
you can't nullify a branch of our checks
and balances it's not a thing it's part
of our democracy it's part of our
constitution keith olbermann has this
[ __ ] wrong
he's got it wrong
sorry keith not one not one that you got
right here
what we need to do
what we need to do is lift up our
democratic institutions
do the math stop banning math and do the
math of how many supreme court justices
were supposed to have on the court and
fight for it fight as hard as they're
willing to fight they fought god damn
hard to buy and pay for these supreme
court justices
to take away our liberty and our right
to safety
and our liberty and our right to our
bodily autonomy
they fought god damn hard for these
fascists to be bought and paid for and
placed on this supreme court and we
should fight just as hard
and use our democracy and our ballot as
the tool
it's there still
it's hanging by a thread but if you
don't use it you will lose it
be damn sure of that
it's time
not tomorrow not next week right [ __ ]
now
right now is the time
and one of the most patriotic things you
can do today
is to go listen to the [ __ ] truth
of what led up to the day of january 6
and the pressure campaign
of the department of justice
another leg of the cheeto dust kangaroo
coup
go listen to the truth
and here's number 12 trending
scotus
is compromised well that's well we've
known that for the last several weeks
hopefully we'll get testimony from
jeannie thomas
about how it is compromised
you know they want to do investigations
on the leak of the decision that's going
to come down tomorrow which is going to
strip away the right that has been
afforded to women for decades in this
country
to their bodily autonomy
they want to oh they want to investigate
the leak but they're not going to
investigate the the q anon nonsense
that the supreme court justice's wife
was trying to rot on our country by
texting mark meadows all kinds of q anon
garbage trying to trying to [ __ ]
convince arizona state legislators and
others
to overturn our election to take away
and steal away our vote [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you
everyone's uh number 15 stacy
is trending i think this is stacy abrams
is trending here
i think it was herschel walker that says
uh if it's something i i'm not i'm not
sure who knows what this word salad
the cte brain dead [ __ ] says
he's got multiple personalities he's got
multiple children that he's never
seen in his life he doesn't claim them
he's he's a psycho and a lunatic with a
gun
we've heard stories of him placing guns
to people's heads in his own head
playing russian
roulette and all kinds of crazy ass [ __ ]
but i think he says let's go in here
let's go on this threat
i think the reason why we're seeing this
is he said something that uh to the
effect that she should be
i don't know
leave he's gonna leave the state if she
wins
now here's the outline or the headline i
don't know if this is why this she's
trending or not georgia guberatorial
candidate stacey abram outlines her
proposal plan to
raise pay for police officers in the and
address the erosion of trust in law
enforcement so that's the headline
and maybe that's true why is this
trending but i think it's because of
this herschel walker statements
what the [ __ ] this can't be true
herschel walker says there's 52 states
ah well god damn
i mean i wouldn't be opposed for for
puerto rico and washington dc to get
statehood i'm all for that herschel
yeah sure i think we could agree on that
that there should be 52 states i there's
not now that's part of the problem
then we can talk about this
let's see what else do we have um
stacy i i think it's something about
moving out of the state
if she wins people are gonna move out of
the state there's i don't know
these [ __ ] people are dumb really
honestly
i guess i guess if it's joking maybe but
if we could clone stacey abrams
and get her to get into our stacey
abrams-esque type folks to go help fight
for our democracy in other states that
would be damn good right about now
we could use that help number 16 is
dobbs
is trending
the u.s supreme court did not release
the decision on dobbs first jackson the
women's health organization case on
thursday and this is alluding to the
fact that we are probably going to see
the ruling to overturn roe v wade and
strip away
women's liberty to the right to their
bodily autonomy uh come down tomorrow
some are even speculating that may be
why they're delaying some of these
hearings you guys know we have a hearing
today
right after the show here we're going to
take a break um
quicker than we normally do we're going
to cut this broadcast about 15 20
minutes than we normally
have uh so we can get prepared for the
january 6 select hearing day 5 over on
the midas touch youtube channel
um and
we we're going to
hear from the doj witnesses over there
so go
go check that out on the midas touch
youtube channel the link is at the top
you can set your reminder there
i will say
um that we will have an hour of coverage
beforehand starting at 2 00 p.m eastern
we're gonna have some a special panel
and we'll talk about the witnesses uh we
have some favorites of the midas mighty
uh maybe the mizellas brothers i know
ben's gonna join us for breaking down
the witnesses i think brett and jordy
might as well join us we have midas
mighty favor texas paul will join us but
also his very special guest ron reagan
ron reagan will join us he did a video
for midas touch about our democracy and
these select hearings he's going to be
joining us
as well
um for those hearings so
i'm going to take a quick break
when we come back
we will go through more of the tweety
tweets and trendy trends stick around
don't go anywhere we will be right back
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
fellow patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50
dollars a day you can help us help those
true americans recover from biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those trump supporters and this is that
moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day
recurring and it means you'll get these
trump supporters the critical help they
so desperately need to survive under
this false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome malonga welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking through the break
and we're gonna we're gonna jump out
just a little early today
so we can set up and get ready for the
january 6th select hearing day number
five we have three witnesses that we're
gonna hear from today
i'm not sure if adam's ship is gonna
question or jamie raskin but we're gonna
hear from the former acting attorney
general jeffrey rosen you guys remember
when bill barr
decided he wasn't going to be part of
federal crimes he resigned uh from the
office of attorney general
it made it sound like that you know it's
all peach and keem but now we know from
testimony
inside inside the january 6 a closed
door room where bill barr had to testify
on her oath that it wasn't all kichi
yeah peachy and keen kichi and peen i
don't know
uh that he was telling him it was all
[ __ ] the cheeto dust monster grandpa
poopy pants was very pissed off was very
upset at him
and i'm i'm sure that's um
one of the reasons why bill barr wanted
to resign he's like ah this federal
crime thing this federal prison thing is
probably not something i want to do so
jeffrey rosen was stepped up to be the
the acting attorney general at the time
because we didn't have a lot of time
between the time that bill barr resigned
because he was supposed to resign after
christmas if you go back and you rewind
a little bit
back to 2020 it was announced that bill
barr was going to resign
after christmas because he wanted to
have a break or some [ __ ] you know he
just can't couldn't stomach the the
additional four weeks that he might have
to work after christmas i don't know it
was all [ __ ] we know that now that
was all nonsense
he knew trump was gonna try to steal the
[ __ ] election and he said nothing
he said [ __ ] nothing jesus christ is
his letter his resignation i love the
president of the united states he's so
awesome i put knee pads on for him every
single day and fluff him the [ __ ] out of
here bill barr again that's like making
mike pence a hero
we see that
we see that he was looking for any
reason he could to give give trump a
good reason why he would just crown him
king he couldn't find one but he was
looking for it
but jeffrey rosen richard donahue
and we're gonna see this in their
testimony we've already seen some of
this uh
testimony leak out through some of these
other hearings you know what they
actually said and through tape
um
here's the thing
is
that richard donahue and jeffrey rosen
said look if you want to make this
jeffrey clark character the attorney
general we quit you're out of your
[ __ ] mind this jeffrey clark person
is willing to commit crimes
for you and trump's like oh yeah that's
what we want woo baby let's get that
jeffrey clark he's willing to commit
crimes in my name to make me king let's
make that guy the attorney general i
like an attorney general who commits
crimes that's what trump was thinking
jeffrey rosen and donnie you're like
you're [ __ ] out of your goddamn gourd
you lost you lost your [ __ ] marbles
the marbles packed their [ __ ] and left
i'm like all right harold get your [ __ ]
we're [ __ ] out of here we're out of
here [ __ ] this [ __ ]
we're gonna go to another marble state
hell
elections have consequences folks
that's why you have to vote
you have to you have to exercise your
right to democracy you have to
at every single inch and it's not just
about going into the ballot box and
marking
the ballot that's not exactly what it's
i mean that's the end result right
like that's the thing you get to
with the right to vote
i mean you you have the right to
register people you had the right to
register yourself you had you had the
right to get people the knowledge about
registering and about voting you had the
right to get people knowledge about the
candidates that they're going to be
voting for you have those rights that's
all part of the right to vote that's all
part of it
and you have to engage you have to
continue to fight for our democracy
and yes
and yes
it's difficult i understand democracy is
difficult i mean i don't agree with
every every democrat every liberal every
democratic socialist every moderate
every independent we're not going to
agree on all these things we're not
we're not going to agree on all the
details but if we stand around debating
the details of a bill that doesn't exist
because we don't have the power to get
that bill to exist that bill will never
exist and it's a waste of [ __ ] breath
it's a waste of hot air and we need to
stop doing it we're all on the team of
democracy that's the one thing that
these fascists are really good at
they're on the team and it doesn't
matter how far they go boy they'll take
it to the very bitter end i mean unless
their own freedom is at stake like rusty
bowers rusty bowers we seen on tuesday
the arizona house speaker was like oh
god damn i didn't want to commit crimes
but then when he left the room and he
was not under oath anymore he told the
associated press god damn right i'd vote
for trump i like that criminal
he threatened me threaten my family hell
he'll probably kill me if he gets back
in power that's why i have to say today
that i'd vote for him because i'm
terrified of of his supporters like eric
greitens to come kick down my door and
[ __ ] murder me with guns
i don't know that's what i [ __ ] saw
it is
i don't think rusty bowers is any kind
of hero i think the january 6 election
many subpoena his ass set him in the
seat and he had to tell the truth under
oath
[ __ ] trump even threatened that
[ __ ] before the hearing
tony he threatened him you goddamn right
he threatened him you god damn right he
threatened him
with that letter he released a statement
basically saying rusty bowers told me
that the election was rigged and rusty
bowers had to sit there after adam's
shift had enough [ __ ] sense to just
ask him the question did you say that
[ __ ] to him he's like no
not only did i not say that [ __ ] to
trump i didn't say that [ __ ] to anybody
even after that rusty bowers walks out
of the room tells the associated price
you goddamn right i would vote for that
fascist you goddamn right i vote for
that guy you tried to overthrown the
government who tried to get me to break
my sacred oath and commit federal crimes
you god damn right
because they're scared
they're scared of people like eric
greitens
they're scared of this idea that people
are going to be carrying around guns
everywhere that this is the wild west
but it's up to you
it's up to you
your right to vote is much is much
stronger
than than
to a well-regulated militia okay your
right to vote is much stronger
it carries much more weight than the
well-regulated militia
you know the gravy seals who have to
carry a bazooka to go order a subway
sandwich
[ __ ]
dumb [ __ ]
but your right to vote is much much more
important much stronger there's way more
thrust
than these ideas uh
speaking of ideals uh the 17 is trending
here on the tweety tweets in trinidrin
federalist society
again we know that the federal society
has bought and paid for
the supreme court and
sheldon winehouse
has done a lot of work
on um
the federalist society and outing them
and getting the information to the
public not a lot of people listen
maybe there's a video here
inside this here's here's a great
graphic here talking about what i was
talking about earlier
uh the geographic boundary you know
there's 13 appellate courts
in the united states of america now in
recent past when we expand the appellate
courts which means we add district or
regions
then we add supreme court justices
for those appellate courts well we
haven't done that the last four times
that we added appellate courts well the
last four appellate courts that we've
added
so it's time that we get the amount of
supreme court justices that we're
supposed to have
we can do math even though republicans
in florida are banning math we can still
do math
so expand the court uh mark had this
posted here i'll retweet this for mark
thank you mark for your tweet
thanks for stopping by the tony michaels
podcast today
okay let's see i'm i want to see if we
can get some sheldon
whitehouse maybe i should just search
sheldon my nails and probably probably
the easiest way because he's um he's had
a lot of
official statements
on
supreme court
uh
using the federal society as a
a bought and paid for
mechanism
for this let me see if i can find
it boom he's gave a lot of statements
inside congress
on this stuff
um
[Music]
i believe
this might be it where he's talking
about big money donors let's listen in
here to this video that sheldon
winehouse has posted on his twitter page
here
the legal theories are actually pretty
easy to come up with
you reverse engineer
you start with what big donor interests
want
and then work backwards
and what lots of big donors want
especially fossil fuel companies
is to weaken and disable
government regulation
regulators stop
all sorts of harmful corporate practices
pollution of our air water and climate
dangerous factory floor working
conditions crooked schemes that cheat
investors
snake oil medications that don't cure
disease
unsafe products
insurance policies that don't pay
the list is long
demolishing
that protective network of regulations
protecting americans health safety and
financial well-being
is a scheme priority
and the destruction begins
by pejoratively naming the agencies
whose work protects us
the administrative state
now there you see a video from sheldon
uh white house on that let's go to some
breaking news here um
getting this across the wires it looks
like it's uh
um it's been about a half hour ago this
was being reported uh catherine here
says breaking federal agents searched
the virginia home of former trump
heiress justice department official
jeffrey clark you've heard me say that
name several times today jeffrey clark
on wednesday morning according to
multiple sources with direct knowledge
of the activity um here are the i'm
going to retweet this so you guys can um
go follow this story and follow these um
track this down
to the people who have it here um it
looks like
what's being reported here is jeffrey
clark as you know i've been saying today
jeffrey clark is the
is the the department of justice
official who donald trump wanted to make
the attorney general and because he
wanted to make um him the attorney
general and jeffrey rosen and richard
donahue threatened to resign
their seats as acting attorney general
and acting deputy attorney general and
the reason why is because rosen and
donahue wouldn't do what trump wanted
which was overturn the election uh
jeffrey clark
was willing to do that apparently i mean
that was the that was the knowledge that
trump had he thought jeffrey clark would
help him in his scheme
as the pressure campaign on the doj was
increased bill barr was ousted and then
jeffrey rose and the donahue were trying
to be ousted by donald trump and jeffrey
clark it looks like wednesday morning uh
so this was yesterday morning uh the
federal agent searched the virginia home
of jeffrey clark you also know that
jeffrey clark has been in held in
contempt of congress um so i don't know
this probably doesn't have to do with
the contempt charges probably has to do
with i don't know
him committing seditious
conspiracy
to overturn our government of the united
states as he took an oath to
just remember that he just [ __ ]
christ
how's this so hard to understand
um so let's go to
again the tweet sweets and trendy trends
we had we got about uh i've got about 10
more minutes 10 or 15 more minutes that
we're going to be on this broadcast and
then we're going to take a quick break
we're going to go over to
um
the midas touch
youtube channel and what we'll do there
is we will we will broadcast
the live hearing day 5
for
uh we will broadcast day five i'm trying
to find the link here sorry about that
yeah i'm running everything by myself
here
gabe sanchez where are you no he's
actually he's busy today
he's busy today so it's just me it's
just me that you got today
um here is the here's the link
in the chat here
um for the link
to the midas touch youtube
video that we will go to as soon as as
soon as the top of the hour comes
which will be two o'clock eastern time
here in about 30 minutes we will start
the broadcast we will start the
commentary for the january 6 select
committee day five
so be sure to find that link set your
reminder and go there at the top of the
hour again we'll we'll be broadcasting
here for about 10 more minutes until we
move over to the january 6 select
committee hearing don't forget while
you're here i know we have a lot of new
viewers here today go ahead and
subscribe to the tony michaels podcast
the youtube page here because we
broadcast every single weekday monday
through friday on youtube twitter twitch
and we also simulcast from the midas
touch facebook page go ahead and
subscribe to the youtube channel very
important
to give us some support because you then
you can come over during the live
broadcast and you can get in the super
chat um yeah and if you don't know what
the super chat is on youtube don't worry
don't worry the great people here the
[ __ ] fam as some of them refer to
themselves
uh the [ __ ] fam will will give you
will give you the rundown of what the
super chat is and how it works and
there's always great conversation in the
super chat
um
we even have some trolls i need to find
some moderators i guess people are
clamoring about monitoring we have more
and more people viewing so we get more
and more trolls we get these we get
these porn bots coming in
and so gabe is usually our moderator
but he's he's not here today so i'm
trying to play all hands but also go
over to our twitter page at tony
michael's pod follow us there because
you know on thursdays and for if for
those new listeners that don't know on
thursdays
we put out a bonehead of the week poll
and i would imagine that three boneheads
are gonna emerge from this
january 6 select hearing what do you
think i bet there's three boneheads that
emerge
from this hearing jeffrey clark is
probably going to be one of them i would
imagine so what we do is we put up a
poll every single week on thursday for
bone end of the week you vote you get to
practice democracy you get to vote
and you can vote on twitter or you can
subscribe to the youtube channel and you
can vote there
but vote for bone out of the week and
then on friday in the second hour of the
show
every single friday me and gabe break
down your vote who you voted for for
bonehead of the week so go follow us at
tonymichaelspod on twitter and follow us
here on youtube for the bonehead of the
week poll where we break it down every
single friday the great part about
bonehead of the week is we post it even
in and of itself on sunday on all the
directories apple spotify google so go
follow us on your favorite directory you
will find us there the tony michaels
podcast for all the new listeners out
there give us a five star review
really really help us out over on all
the directories but don't forget we also
have a best of
saturday edition so we actually publish
on those directories every single day
every single day seven days a week
during
the week
but you get the uh you get the live
broadcast after we're done you get that
posted on the directories so that's a
two hour broadcast
so bk paying attention for that also on
the directories again we've got about 10
more minutes before we go over to before
we take a quick break and then at the
top of the hour so 30 minutes from now
we will start
the coverage of the january 6 select
committee day five where the department
of justice officials will be testifying
an open public
about what they knew about the scheme of
the cheeto dust kangaroo coup
so make sure to go over to the midas
touch youtube channel at the top of the
hour and listen to the broadcast of the
january 6 hearing we will have an hour
of commentary to tell you about some of
our guests we will have on that in that
first panel i think we're gonna have ben
my zealous and a couple of minus touch
brothers i'm not sure exactly he's gonna
i know ben's gonna do a breakdown of the
witnesses for us of what it means who
these are why it's significant what he
thinks they're probably going to say uh
we'll get that from ben mizelis from
legal af and the midas touch podcast
ben's the big bro over there the mighty
mighty know that so we'll hear from ben
on the witnesses we're also i think
jessica denson is going to be joining us
you know jessica
gave a very very passionate
rant and reaction to the testimony on
tuesday after mrs moss and her mother
lady ruby and they even talked about her
grandmother
were threatened and pressured by the
trump administration and
the maga team maga
team abnormal i guess you could call it
um with rudy giuliani and donald trump
himself putting their names and their
mouths
and really pressuring them to even move
out of their house
um and she gave a heartfelt rant jessica
denson did because she is the trump nda
killer so hopefully she'll be joining us
and one of the midas mighty's favorite
texas paul will be joining us but our
very very special guest we have david
bender back everyone's been loving their
political strategist david bender
and his view on things but ronald
reagan's son president ronald reagan ron
reagan who did a video who did a video
for midas touch about the january 6th
hearing will be joining us live
ron reagan will be joining us live on
our broadcast
today
at the top of the hour here um we will
we will be joined by ron reagan so you
don't want to miss that commentary you
definitely don't want to miss the
hearings but you don't want to miss the
commentary either we're going to have
some special guests talking us to us
today we'll also do commentary during
the break so here's what we do for all
the listeners out there that want to
know how we run the uh hearing
production so we do commentary before we
play the hearing
and just the hearing so you can listen
you can focus on the hearing and then if
they go to a break we'll be giving
commentary during that break when they
break
when the hearing gavels down for a
recess and then after the hearing is
over when they end the hearing
we will go to more commentary depending
on when they end and how much time we
have
then we'll do some more commentary there
with a panel of guests
so stick around after the hearing
to listen to the commentary there so
join us at the top of the hour on the
midas touch youtube channel
for day 5 of the january 6th select
hearing
don't forget to go over there and set
your reminder um we're going to head out
here in about five minutes which is a
little early for the tony michaels
podcast as all the listeners know out
there normally we go to the top of the
other
but i'm alone today so i have to i have
to prep a little bit
um for
the broadcast so i will hop off here and
i will be moving over to the midas touch
youtube channel for all of you out there
that's where you will find me at the top
of the hour for the hearing for the
special commentary with ben mizelis the
my zelis brothers
jessica denson i think michael cohen may
be joining us if he has time i know he's
kind of got some appointments that he's
trying to he's trying to work in to get
to us for that hour we have the midas
mighty favor texas paul also ron reagan
will be joining us and david bender uh
and ron reagan i think are going to be
taking us into the hearing and really
giving us uh sort of
even historical uh what this means to
have the department of justice uh folks
the acting attorney general for donald
trump in december 2020 in january 2020
when the january 6th siege on the
capitol happened when donald trump
attempted the cheeto dust kangaroo coup
the doj's
former acting attorney general jeffrey
rosen will be testifying in the open
public we've seen this before
where justice department officials have
testified
an open public
for watergate
so maybe we'll get some historic insight
into that as well so you're definitely
going to want to join us over there
let's see if there's any more breaking
news boy it's a huge breaking news day
we have the news that jeffrey clark um
the the doj official that donald trump
wanted to replace as the attorney
general because
he knew he would help him overturn the
united states constitution and make him
king and bring us into an authoritarian
state jeffrey clark was willing to do
that it seemed and i think we're going
to find that out today with the
testimony
other breaking news is the second
amendment
decision coming down from the supreme
court today that strikes down the new
york gun law restricting
concealed carry handguns um which is a
front to everyone's safety and your your
right to move and freely and feel safe
now so it's they're taking
we're taking rights away there but they
what they
they can't regulate guns but they sure
as hell can regulate e-cigarettes we see
the fda banning a jewel e-cigarettes
they'll ban e-cigarettes can't ban guns
no can't do that [ __ ] um we also we also
have the news of tomorrow it seems
because the supreme court did not make
the decision on overturning roe v wade
today that decision of dobbs did not
drop um so everyone is assuming that
tomorrow so the news is that the news is
tomorrow
for the supreme court to decide to strip
away
the liberty and the rights of women to
their bodily autonomies in this country
which is
gross
and vile and we must fight back with our
vote we must fight back with our
democracy and i know all you folks out
there are pro-democracy
i know in your heart of hearts you
really do believe in our democracy and
the advancement of our democracy and i
know that you you are
rest assured that it will deliver us
equality and equity and it's difficult
and it's hard and it's not perfect
and it's not always the exact equity and
equality that we want to achieve but
we progress and we get better and we get
better and better every single moment
every single day as we progress
these pro-democracy ideas
so fight with your vote
while you still have it
it's a republic
if you can keep it
again join me here in just a few moments
at the top of the hour in about 20
minutes
i will move to the midas touch youtube
channel
let me put the link in the chat one last
time
so that you guys have the link here
for the link
here is the link the youtube link there
you go
to move to the midas touch youtube
channel i will be moving to that link
in just under 20 minutes we're going to
take a quick
break and move to the midas touch
youtube channel so go over there right
now
don't hesitate go over there right now
to the midas touch youtube channel get
set get ready because we are gonna stop
start the commentary at the very top of
the hour
and then tomorrow we'll be back at our
normal time here on youtube twitter and
twitch and the midas touch facebook page
simulcasting
i'll see you in 20 minutes until then
surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking